it's important to remember that Holmes
wasn't born Holmes Holmes was born like
you and me but probably with you know
greater potential for certain elements
of observation but he learned over time
to think like Sherlock Holmes at the
beginning he probably thought more like
Watson because that's more of our
natural state he's able to attain what
he does because he's become an expert of
sorts at observing he's become an expert
at person perception what I mean by this
as he has thousands and thousands of
hours of practice and that practice has
been interwoven with feedback so I look
at you and I tell you something about
yourself and you say no that's actually
wrong that has nothing to do with me at
all or you say wow how did you know that
so I'm learning which details matter
which details don't matter which
observations are logical which ones are
false and over time I build up that
expertise that will allow me to look at
you and in one second say hey Watson I
think you've been in Afghanistan and it
seems like it's completely just out of
the blue oh my god how did he know that
but then if you go back you'll see that
this is not intuition in the sense of
just I knew it it's intuition than the
sense of expertise in the sense of
judgment that has been honed over years
and years of practice so for Holmes the
entire thought process is akin to a
scientist who is doing a research
experiment so someone who is who is
doing kind of who's following the
scientific method so for him the mind is
like an attic and what that means is you
can store only so much in it the space
is finite and what you store and how you
store it is incredibly important as you
try to figure out how do i optimize my
mental resources how do I then take the
things I've stored and access them how
do I organize them so that there are
connections between them so that I can
use them and make them as part of kind
of a broader whole so I can see the
bigger picture and not just these random
components that I put there so what a
researcher would do at the beginning of
an experiment is to say
you know what is my question and that's
exactly what Holmes does he says what is
my goal what do I want to accomplish
before he ever opens the case before he
ever meets a client he already wants to
know what is it that I want to get from
this meeting and so he comes into the
meeting with a prepared mind set his
attic has already been primed so to
speak to take in certain inputs and to
not allow other inputs in this is
important because attention is
incredibly finite and so we don't have
just endless resources so we can't pay
attention to everything we do need to be
selective in what we pay attention to
now the scientist after kind of setting
this hypothesis would say okay how would
I go about testing it that's once again
exactly what Sherlock Holmes does after
he says his goals he goes about
observing and collecting data and asking
ok how do I answer this question and
what is it about this conversation about
this person about the situation whatever
it happens to be that will enable me to
gather the data that I will then be able
to use to see whether my hypothesis
holds up and then he does this thing
that every great scientist does and I
think mediocre scientists probably do
not which is take a step back and learn
to look at the data recombine it look at
different possibilities be imaginative
with that data to see is there anything
that I didn't think of beforehand is my
mind still open do I still know what's
going on does this data somehow make me
think of new ideas think of new
approaches think of things that I hadn't
thought of in the past and so he has
this incredible space for imagination
and I think that that is an essential
part of the scientific method as well
you know scientists from Feynman to
Einstein have really valued the
importance of imagination and have
spoken a lot about it so the reason I'm
stressing this is because people tend to
forget it when they think about the
scientific method now finally what you
do after that is you go back to the data
and you look at the kind of what you've
done with it and you see what makes
sense based on my observations have I
framed the question properly have I
accomplished my goal or do I need to
start over
because it's an iterative process you
may need to go through this method over
and over and over until you finally come
to a conclusion and that's kind of the
final step of Holmes's approach he
always keeps his education going he
realizes that the scientific method
doesn't have an end you're always going
to have to go back to the beginning it's
going to be a constant feedback loop